Hey youtubers it’s charlie and by popular
demand here’s my Game of Thrones Season
4 preview for Brienne of Tarth.
Today as of posting this video it’s also
George RR Martin’s birthday, so he can’t
refuse any of your requests.
Or is that his daughter’s wedding day.
I don’t think he has a daughter though.
So let’s roll the dice on that one.
Spoiler warning for everything in the first
three seasons and partial spoilers for feast
for crows.
Like I said before Brienne is one of my favorite
characters on Game of Thrones.
It’s really the actors Gwendoline Christie
and Nikolai Coster Waldeau that I have to
thank for that.
When I first read the books honestly I spent
more time focused on the Jaime character after
they started traveling together.
But after seeing them re-interpret things
for the show I really feel like when they’re
together it’s really Brienne’s story and
Jaime is just passing through.
Think of like Star Wars being a story about
this R2 droid’s adventures across this sixty
or seventy year span (he will be in episode
7).
And all the jedi masters and cool bounty hunters
he meets along the way.
Brienne is like the last good thing in westeros,
her story is really all about this totally
pure dream of becoming this glorious knight
defending her king and the realm.
Like what the King’s Guard is supposed to
be all about but totally fails at.
In reality there is almost no honor amongst
the gold cloaks.
But throughout the series she just sticks
to her guns and takes Jaime back to Kings
Landing.
Obviously some of her sense of honor and duty
rubs off on Jaime and they have some epic
fandom moments like the world’s most intense
bath scene.
But I really think that Brienne will have
a much more independent story line in Season
4.
At the end of season 3 the last we saw of
her was saying goodbye to Jaime in the finale
once they’d reached King’s Landing.
Since the show accelerated their story line
so much I expect that trend to continue and
Brienne will take on another quest.
Because what is a knight without a quest.
But there’s one big thing Brienne still
needs to deal with now that she’s back in
King’s Landing.
Remember she fled Renly’s camp in season
2 after the smoke baby gave him the shaft.
Since she was one of the only people in the
tent when they found him she and Catelyn got
blamed for murdering him.
They basically never resolved that plot point.
So everyone who doesn’t understand that
magic was involved still thinks she killed
him.
Including his boyfriend Loras.
Who just happens to be in King’s Landing
getting ready to marry cersei.
The first couple of episodes will pretty much
wrap up that storyline and Jaime will be forced
to rescue Brienne from Loras again.
Since it’s a relatively minor plot point
compared to the other things happening in
Kings Landing I don’t know how much of a
scene it will get.
But chronologically it happens before Brienne
does anything else in the books.
Here’s where we need to talk about a few
spoilers for Brienne in the second half of
Book 3.
So remember I mentioned she needs another
quest, otherwise she won’t have an opportunity
to try and help Catelyn.
The whole point in bringing Jaime back was
to trade for Sansa and Arya who everyone thinks
are still in King’s Landing.
Here’s where the show kind of messes with
things.
In the books when Brienne gets to King’s
Landing Sansa has already fled with Littlefinger
to the Vale and the Eyrie.
But because she’s still there in the show
I think they’re going to change some of
Brienne’s story.
I still think they’re going to send her
on another quest and they’ll still give
her Oathkeeper.
But I think the way the show will explain
it is that Brienne will end up being ordered
to bring Sansa back to King’s Landing.
Here’s a quick breakdown of how I think
all this will go down.
First, Brienne and Jaime deal with a really
pissed off Loras.
Two, Brienne doesn’t get any scenes for
an episode or two, three a super duper spoiler
mega event happens, four sansa flees kings
landing with Littlefinger and then five Brienne
is ordered to find her and bring her back
under the explanation that she’s been kidnapped.
Let me know what you think of my season 4
timeline for Brienne.
Like i’ve said earlier the show is changing
a lot so they’ve already messed with the
timeline from the books.
So it definitely won’t happen exactly that
way during season 4 for those who have read
ahead.
Since so many of you have requested him I’ll
be doing my next video for Stannis be sure
to subscribe to get it.
I’ll post it on monday.
Obviously I’ll have to follow that with
Melisandre.
As always make sure to let me know in the
comments which other characters you want to
talk about next and I’ll add them to my
list.
And in case you didn’t see, I just started
a special Sherlock-themed giveaway.
I posted a video explaining it.
You can click here to check out my other game
of thrones season 4 previews and you can click
here to learn about that Sherlock Giveaway.
Thanks so much for watching, I’ll see you
tonight for Legend of Korra.